[Music]
here we are in the whole valley
rainforest this is a cathedral my
cathedral in this forest is the quietest
place in the entire United States and
it's only one square inch of the size my
mission is to keep it that way
I'm Gordon Hempton I'm a sound tracker I
travel the globe in search of vanishing
sounds including the most endangered of
all which is simply silence noise
pollution is nearly enix capable the
whole valley is the quietest least noise
polluted place and the entire lower 48 I
don't know if I can save silence but I
know that I can try so it was 12 years
ago
2005 Earth Day that I hiked up the HOH
River Valley
it took three miles just to escape the
notice of the parking lot that's when I
was looking in every direction for which
way I should go
I saw the elk trail love to follow their
advice because they love quiet just like
I do
and they led me right to the spot I
defend this one square inch of silence
by doing both quiet and noise monitoring
when a noise intrusion occurs I locate
the noise maker send them a letter and
ask for compliance this matter is urgent
within ten years it's likely that there
will be no quiet places left unless we
take action when I first started I did
not think silence would go extinct in my
lifetime
and if that happens the quiet will
disappear and the wildlife will be
devastated the one square inch of
silence foundation is pressing our
politicians to pass a single piece of
legislation that will designate Olympic
National Park as the world's first quiet
park off-limits to aircraft all things
are possible the earth is here and it's
beautiful and for me it all starts here
in the whole valley para para nice
kujaku sonidos I have a cadence Oneiros
muy bonitas habakkuk in Antonio we
simply show local Cersei a go disfruta
lisara that Reforma sonido al assad
param es la forma con la que tengo the
appreciate the me
mi nombre home below Collazo yas a
Catorce A&E ok registro law so liadrin
at rallies so say say go Danis in en tow
lo único que puedo ver son loses me
mundo son sonidos s todo todo tipo de
información que reciben Premila bar
Senora
Belloc para para nice couch Isuzu Nero's
Palace in Pajaro cantando cuando couch
Oh Samuel
Mme entender sha sha la estoy bien los
economy no message called Anna Maria
fault Avalos para me el sonido al assad
is musical antonio el frente veo dinner
solo de música el viene al se de poner
OTN UN canto muy muy extra dente SE
puede cuchara a Rondo distancia de
puesta Nestle taro con su sonido muy
famoso KS teru teru teru todo el tiempo
el canto mama lo de cosas que podemos
tener Y case else or Sol Sol Sol tiene
UN silver que trae Mucha pas la
importancia de registrar la sabes gusta
mint a la construcción en el trabajo que
a really so Descartes re oveja trail
goes ownio de la sabes s tambien parte
de de nuestro patrimonio natural
lamentable mint al ser humano lowest
extrusion entonces para me grab our cada
sonido en un lugar de Tinto honest como
tener UN registro es como dare a un para
cito decay lugar
[Music]
every place in the world sounds unique
these soundscapes that tell us a story
about that place they tell us the ways
in which global warming is beginning to
change the natural soundscape just
before the Sun rises at first light is
the dawn chorus the birds begin to sing
and the insects and the amphibians and
that's the time of day to go out and
listen I'm a soundscape
ecologist that record animals for a
living this is Sugarloaf State Park
every spring I can probably be found
there once a week recording in the same
spot using the same kind of equipment so
that I can repeat these recordings over
and over again and compare them
and I have quite a archive of material
which shows over time this habitat has
been changing pretty radically there's a
result of global warming and the
California drought the first recording
made in 2004 shows a very robust habitat
with a signature of a stream in 2014
things were changing radically it was
already the second year of a major
drought in California and in 2015 we had
what I call a Silent Spring over 50% of
my collection comes from habitats that
are so radically altered they're either
altogether silent or no longer be heard
in their original form here's an example
from Costa Rica
[Music]
that's before logging this is after
same spot this is a coral reef the new
allez-vous and Fiji part of it is dying
and part of it is still living here's
what the living part sounds like here's
what the dying part sounds like hardly
any fish sounds
we really don't know what this means in
the long run in the short run were
beginning to lose these soundscapes
because habitats are just changing so
radically and we're partly to blame for
them when I first began to record almost
fifty years ago I would go out into the
field and just put on a pair of
earphones and sit and listen because it
made me feel good it made me aware of
the living world around me and so I want
to do anything that does that for me the
weather is really in your face in New
Orleans it is a character in the play of
New Orleans
[Music]
this instrument the weather warlock is
an audio mirror of the sunrise and
sunset so theoretically a blind person
could experience the sunrise and sunset
through audio in real time
my name is Quintron it's not my real
name it's a given musician's name I
definitely consider myself first and
foremost to be a musician but I'm also a
builder an inventor of electronic
musical instruments and the device that
we're talking about today is called the
weather warlock which is a weather
controlled analog synth right now we're
hearing the Sun just start to activate
the UV sensors on the outdoor sensor
unit that puttering sound is the sound
of that sensor just starting to get
enough light to sonically activate it
it's using the weather to create music
there's no microphones there's no it's
not the sound of rain there are two
components an inside set of brains which
is the synthesizer part and an outdoor
set of sensors there is a temperature
sensor which is affecting the speed of
the drone this drone there is a set of
wind speed controlled sensors the faster
the wind blows the faster they activate
these two notes there is a moisture
sensor or rain or humidity or snow the
last one would be the sky sensor which
is a sensor at the top and a little
periscope that's aiming at the sky so
you can play it like an instrument too
you can just let it do its thing but I
can also you know
[Music]
so sunrise is officially over
according to the weather warlock and
everyone else
[Music]
check one two good evening you are tuned
in to weather for the blind dot o-r-g
broadcasting as usual out of New Orleans
Louisiana the weather warlock has become
a live 24/7 online musical feed sunrise
was at 5:15 this morning and sunset
happening now as you can hear according
to our UV sensors
this hasn't made me see a sunset
differently you can just hear it now
[Music]
welcome to Hanson on the remote place on
the west coast of Canada
about ten kilometers long and two
kilometers wide this island belongs to
two groups and First Nations and the oka
for most of my life I've had the great
good fortune of living here in this
incredible environment and studying this
herbal creature and it's given me a
sense of peace I want everybody to have
that same experience
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Paul Spong and 47 years ago
I was a young scientist at the
University of British Columbia and part
of my job was to study an author in
captivity at the Vancouver Aquarium I
came to understand that authors are
acoustic creatures because they're using
sound to locate their prey to get what
they need to live from sound
they should not be penned up in concrete
tanks that deprived them of the sound of
the ocean that they were born into
ultimately that knowledge led me to
search for a place in the wild where I
could study office totally without
interfering with them and that search
led me to Hanson Island where I said a
polka lab we build a network of
half-a-dozen hydrophones that cover 50
square kilometers of the surrounding
area and they give us live audio so we
can track their movements often 24 hours
a day 60 60 area for me one of the
greatest experiences here is putting on
a pair of earphones and just listening
and then we have speakers in the forest
here the temps near the outhouse near
the camp kitchen all of the spaces
around here
one of the things you can't help
noticing and feeling is the sudden
inclusion of a boat of a vessel of a
propeller it's jarring
[Applause]
[Music]
here at Orca lab we listen to untold
quantities of boat noise it's really
annoying we can always walk away from it
but whales can't with disruptive
communication it disrupts their ability
to hunt I think from a point of view of
the welfare of the whales something that
has to be dealt with what I want to do
is develop the ability for people to get
to feel empathy for the creature since
2000 we've streamed live audio so that
anybody with computer access to the
Internet can listen to exactly what we
listen to in our lab what we're trying
to do is give people a taste of what it
is to be an author in this magnificent
environment in doing that they will come
to care and want to protect nature
I believe that if I can share what I
have experienced the world could not
peace
[Music]